we don't John Federman was the only
Democrat to embarrass themselves during
a debate New York Governor Kathy hokel
forced to confront surging crime during
her matchup against Republican Lee
zeldin she was completely baffled by the
concept of jailing criminals
we can either work on keeping people
scared or he could focus on keeping them
safe I have worked hard to have real
policies that are making a difference
Kathy hokel believes that the only
crimes that are being committed are
these crimes with guns and you've got
people who are afraid of being pushed in
front of oncoming subway cars they're
being stabbed beaten to death on the
street with hammers for that what are we
halfway through the debate she still
hasn't talked about locking up anyone
committing any crimes okay anyone who
commits a crime under our laws
especially with the change we made to
bail has consequences I don't know why
that's so important to you all I know is
that we could do more can't blame that
on a stroke and the ladies of the view
seem to be stumped on why people even
care about crime
I think most people having been a
prosecutor I know this they care about
violent crimes they don't care about
Broken Window crimes they really don't
care about that as much violent crimes
in the last few months Lee zeldin was
nearly stabbed on stage while
campaigning in New York Ebola he came
within 30. yeah that's not okay though
that means
God if we didn't have the view we'd have
huge blank spaces in our show it's
incredible you know Dana that's uh I
think I think zeldin kind of helped
expose the problem with this this uh
governor who wasn't elected is that
she's disconnected with what with real
concerns I think do you remember that
when crime was happening she was her big
thing was pronouns she was able to get
the SUNY campuses to enforce their
pronoun laws do you remember the real
estate pronoun laws that's what you
those were what she called the victims
were the pronouners
and it was also very interesting I felt
that he his energy matched the voter's
concern yeah right and that hers did not
because her she's like sitting back she
not see the polls where the number one
issue in New York for devoters is crime
and then and then down a little bit
lower than that is the economy and
inflation so that should have been
something I think that she should have
been able to match the concern of the
voter with her energy she did not do
that I thought his answer was very good
as well when talking about all the other
types of crimes that you see and people
are very much worried about broken
windows as we talk about it all the time
that's the philosophy that when you let
that stuff go everything else comes up
also how could hocal say that these
criminals end up with consequences when
with cash-free bail we've seen it over
and over again how many times do we tell
a story like well this person now this
victim was killed turns out oh guess
what he had a rap sheet a mile long and
just got out last month uh after a
burglary charge the other the other
thing I would point out is when she says
to zeldon on crime I don't know why
that's so important to to you it
reminded me of when do you remember
Terry McAuliffe in Virginia running
against Glenn youngkins said I don't
think parents should tell teachers what
to teach their kids yeah that line was a
gift to the zelding campaign if they use
it yeah it's a very what judge it's like
it's a very what difference does it make
absolutely but it's
it's who Kathy hokel is I call her The
Accidental Governor I mean no one voted
her in uh but it is this arrogant kind
of condescending you know let the people
eat cake uh you know you might take yeah
I did make a cake today but that's
another issue
um you know but why why are you so
concerned about it you know um with the
changes I don't know why that's so
important to you this woman is clueless
she is clueless if you listen to the
whole debate and I did there was very
little she said about what she was going
to do she didn't talk about the economy
crime taxes or energy what she talked
about was the fact that we're putting we
are paying 600 million dollars for the
Buffalo Bills stadium of which I believe
her husband has a piece it doesn't own
the actual concession and the other
piece that she talked about is the covet
Mass when Lee Zelda brought it up where
she paid 637 million or whatever that is
double the amount of masks everywhere
else in the country and she got got a
big contribution this is a woman who's
part of the pay for play corruption in
Albany Lee zeldon was on his game he
talked every issue whether it was crime
the economy energy he knows what the
issues are and she says what what is
crime to you my god there was a shooting
in front of his house while his
daughters were home somebody came up to
attack him on a stage this woman is in
la la land yes and you know what else
I'll tell you what else when she was
with a Cuomo I don't think she learned a
thing because he kept her in the
background yeah she was just there for
you know when they needed a lieutenant
governor she was however somewhat
polished you know she knew how to say no
I've never been engaged in any kind of
corruption but she never said what she
was going to do for New Yorkers Lee
zeldin killed it um you know Harold in
the green room I was really struck when
you said I like the cut of Lee zeldon's
jib I'm going to try to vote for him
twice I said Harold that's illegal and
you said that's the way I roll and then
you just hit me in the face and it was
just totally ridiculous I don't remember
it uh quite like that but uh but I'll
take your word so look I I think zeldon
had a pretty good night
um I thought and to your point and judge
I think you were saying it as well I
thought that Governor hokel would have
spelled out three or four things that
she had done two or three things
differently she was going to do and one
or two things even bigger she was going
to do if elect reelected or I should say
elected because she's never been elected
there might have been a missed
opportunity there but I I think Lee
zeldon's challenge
um is that he's pro-life that he's
connected to to to Mr Trump former
president Trump and I think what what
the governor thinks is if she's able to
connect him to to those two factors that
that will prevent him from running up
any significant vote here in New York
City which makes up 40 percent of the
voters we all know the five boroughs
though we'll have to wait and see what
happens but he said on the abortion
issue he won't change the law in New
York he's not concerned about that that
the law in New York as it relates to
abortion is fine it's not one of these
zealots coming and saying right but so I
think I think Democrats would argue well
there were people in the Supreme Court
who said that and look what happened so
um I'm just we just are analyzing the
debate here we're not necessarily so I
think that's where his challenge is but
if I were her I'd have certainly spell
that I use it as an opportunity to spell
out here's what we're doing on crime
here's what's been wrong here's what
we're going to do to fix it and here's
what I'm gonna do the next four years to
bring more jobs and Investments uh and
make health care more affordable all
across the state I didn't hear that from
either of them so Jesse pretend that you
watched the debate when in fact you were
just hanging out in a hot tub
laughs
I watched the debate in the hot tub so
if you're giving a speech you can get
away with platitudes but if you're in a
debate you have to get specific and
Kathy had no specifics did you notice in
the clip she goes well I've pushed
policies that do anything for Crime name
a policy yeah she hasn't pushed any
specific policy and Lee was specific
about bail and about the types of crimes
being committed about sentencing and
psych wards so that was good
it used to be considered racist to let
black neighborhoods kill each other that
used to be considered racist by not
policing black neighborhoods by not
Prosecuting black on black crime but
today's Democrats
are back to that Yep they're not
policing and they think that's somehow
not racist in fact it is so David you're
right you have to connect to the streets
and she can't connect at all you can see
her eyes are glassy she's got no emotion
and the country right now especially New
York is emotional and they're emotional
about crime
The View if you get picked up in a town
car from a upper east side doorman
building and then get chauffeured to a
nice Studio that's guarded by former
NYPD officers and then shuttled back
you're not really in touch with the
people and you can't say crime's not an
issue when that's your lifestyle that's
a good point because we we live similar
Lifestyles but we are like we talk most
of us walk in the city
we know how bad crime is for sunny
housing to say it's it's nobody cares
about that yeah they're not walking
around her feet don't touch the ground
but in addition to that it shows her
naivete she says people are only worried
about violent crime you know we don't
care about broken windows she doesn't
understand the concept the broken
windows are one of the ways to prevent
the higher more violent crime